1994 michel houellebecq présente son
premier roman extension du domaine de la
lutte lors de l'émission le cercle de
minuit clope au bec nonchalant c'est
l'une des premières apparitions télé
d'un écrivain qui va devenir un
phénomène littéraire et médiatique
en vieillissant on est tous confrontés
une forme de pression inévitable
quatre ans plus tard il se fait
connaître du grand public avec le livre
les particules élémentaires
et deux camps s'affrontent écrivains
contemporains de génie qui dépeint une
société gangrénée pour les uns simple
provocateur sans contenu est hostile
plat pour d'autres en 2001 quand sort
plateforme son troisième roman abordant
le tourisme sexuel en thaïlande la
machine est relancée fois qu'on assiste
à un truc nouveau c'est une éruption du
solde du star system dans la littérature
française où elle devait qu'à la
première star littéraire française le
roman est catalogué d' apologie de la
pédophilie
l'auteur continue la provocation en
disant que l'islam est la religion la
plus con du monde réactions en plateau
se discute comme dire ce que je pense ça
j'en serai ça dépend des jours où ses
sorties médiatiques font à chaque fois
la une rebelote pour la sortie de la
possibilité d'une île en 2005 un tapage
médiatique qui en agace certains je
dénonce une double imposture dans le cas
du houellebecq à une imposture le
littéraire qui consiste à faire passer
un auteur à mon avis de second ordre
pour un génie de la littérature et puis
il ya une imposture médiatique c'est à
dire qu' un tapage qui est organisée de
telle manière qu'on ne laisse pas le
choix aux lecteurs une sorte de
sidération du lecteur qui est persuadé
qu'il a affaire un grand écrivain peu
importe ses critiques les livres se
vendent et éclipse tous les autres lors
des rentrées littéraires ils sont
traduits et s'exporte à travers le monde
le suivant la carte et le territoire
aura même le prix goncourt
vous êtes heureux je trouve honteux en
2015 sortie du roman d'anticipation
soumission l'action se passe en 2022 et
le locataire de l'élysée et musulmans
l'écrivain est accusé d'islamophobie
houellebecq lui s'en défend et brouille
les pistes vous qui êtes plutôt réservé
plutôt à l'écart est ce que vous aimez
ça finalement la polémique parce que
vous semblez la chercher
je peux pas dire que j'aime mais je fais
pas non plus d'efforts pour l'éviter
quoi dire je vais pas éviter un sujet
parce que je sais qu'il est polémique en
2019 sérotonine l'histoire d'un quadra
dépressif dans le monde agricole david
pujadas pense alors avoir percé le
mystère houellebecq vous dit ma mère
elle n'a pas été assez tendre ça
explique tout aujourd'hui lorsqu'une
femme refuse de me toucher de me
caresser j'en éprouve une souffrance
atroce intolérable est-ce que ça
n'explique pas votre vision si sombre de
votre époque de notre époque ce monde si
dur et si vide que vous décrivez
régulièrement
au fond je crois pas dépressif
opportuniste ou vrai génie le débat est
encore une fois relancé pendant que des
critiques débattent michel houellebecq
silencieux explose les chiffres de vente
[Musique]